so in the middle of this actual
wrestling match
because he's getting sock in the face
and he's a crazy dude he takes out a
knife and he starts literally stabbing
the guy
up to like 14 times
[Music]
all right so this is gonna be just a
straight up story time I mentioned the
existence of this dude one day and uh I
think people got really interested
because I was watching a video on him
recently and in the comments a bunch of
people are like I'm here from JK
and a bunch of people like me too me too
me too and I think just me even just
saying his name got a bunch of people to
look it up so I thought I would just
tell the whole story of this guy and
it's a really entertaining story it is
about uh a professional wrestler named
new Jack
oh yes this guy right here
he's probably one of the most remarkable
anomalies in wrestling he was in he
looks like KRS one kind of Kinda Yeah he
was in the ECW which is kind of the more
hardcore ones where people are like
bloody and like basically backyard
wrestling oh wow yeah and he was super
super hardcore but let's start at the
beginning because his life
is pretty insane so uh basically he was
born in 1968 in North Carolina
he actually as a child witnessed his
father stabbed his mother multiple times
after he found out she was cheating five
months later he shot her in the leg when
she tried to take him and and uh leave
oh wow so after the stabbing she stuck
around yeah I stuck around and then his
dad died of a heart attack him his mom
moved away [__] he took a bunch of like
different jobs talk about don't
constantly I know he had a rough life by
age 15 he's him and his friends are
robbing stores gas stations jewelry
stores they eventually got caught
after his release he was in for two
years he became a truck driver and then
for a decade he was a bounty hunter
which is pretty freaking crazy that's a
cool job there's actually three major
events in wrestling that make this dude
super super Infamous and we're gonna go
through each one uh the first one is the
in the year 2000 this is known as the
Vic Grimes fall
and I'll let him explain it to you here
on what he did it's pretty crazy
three I can't do it I said [__] you
we're going on three so look at this
forehead bro one two three
oh I never recovered
so he's blinding his right eye from that
and it cracked the skull because it it
broke the fall because the dude was
hesitating and he just said no we're
going and pulled him down that was in
2000. so because of that uh certain
event he was complaining that Vic Grimes
the guy that fell with him like never
checked on him when he was in the
hospital so he had kind of a beef with
him two years later that [__] guy
he's like you pulled me down I told you
no two years later they have another
match
and uh they're gonna do another fall he
this dude is such a crazy guy that
whatever fall he does he's always trying
to top it so he ends up doing another
match with Vic Grimes two years later
and actually admits that he was trying
to kill him during this one oh my he was
trying to kill commit crimes
but look at how insanely high this one
is
oh what the [__]
he was coked out for this too
he broke taser up he used a taser
what the f oh [__] did the holy [__]
so it hit the ring
hit the table
fools that this guy was not at least
paralyzed
oh hit the table first
God how many floors is that that's like
four floors or five floors what the [__]
he was so mad at the guy that he
literally was like he wanted him to die
imma try to kill someone [__] yeah
it's crazy so that dude only like by
sheer luck survived like he he uh wasn't
supposed to land that way still is he
alive like is he like taught like can
you comment dick Grimes I don't know if
he's still alive actually dude the scars
on his forehead on new Jack's forehead I
know so he has if you're wondering what
those words are if you don't know like
ECW or any of those hardcore wrestling
they do these pre-cuts where they'll
like razor their uh forehead so that
it's gonna bleed during the match
uh they did it on purpose and then if
you do it so many times you just end up
looking like well they do it they they
actually bring glass in their socks and
then they grab and then they they go
grab it and they they do that like like
during moves or whatever or after they
take a hit with a chair or whatever then
they're cutting it up under the but
those are the scars from that for sure
so the the third and most craziest
incident that he had in wrestling is
this one this is in 2004. uh he's blind
in one eye this whole time yeah he's
blending on it so he's scheduled to
fight this guy named William Lane
um basically what happens is during the
fight
he's not really selling his punches so
even though uh new Jack is hitting them
the dude is like he's not working with
him and then he's punching him
and Landing him like completely he's
like actually socking new full-on
punches full-on punching him full power
so new Jack
doesn't take copy to that at all and uh
tries to throw him off a balcony
this is what happens so in the middle of
this actual wrestling match
because he's getting shocked in the face
and he's a crazy dude he takes out a
knife and he starts literally stabbing
the guy
up to like 14 times he just has a knife
on him yes yes
this is really high as well yeah during
a during a wrestling show what is he
covered in he's in camo so he's holding
the guy right now and he's taking it out
of his right hip
it looks like a big knife and he's
literally trying to stab him to death oh
my God are they like what the [__] is
this real it's real it 100 happens are
people looking at it do they know that
it's real there's barely anyone there
there's like 30 people in attendance
it's not even paper what the [__]
yeah so this guy's just literally
bleeding out so now we know he doesn't
do it for the audience [__] yeah for
sure right right he's just a [__]
psychopath that oh my God before the
studies the Showman
you think his dad [__] him up so
people are just watching him kill
somebody yeah so what happened is he
ends up uh security comes in they try to
take the knife from him he ends up
getting arrested and uh Goes to Jail the
guy that he stabbed is such a fan of new
Jack that he actually says hey
if we can turn this into an angle
and we take the show on the road and we
do like a Revenge match
I'll drop all charges why would you even
want to be in this he doesn't even get
roomless that guy after that yeah so he
did the cameras follow the ambulance of
the hospital because that's real so so
that was in new Jack's head that he
wasn't selling it and he's like hitting
me full power so he justified it by he
just snapped and just did that so that
he did what if he's in the hospital
right and then he's like oh doctor thank
you and then doctor turns around this
new jacket
you said the guy
the dude actually recovers but then he
tells new Jack like I want to work with
you like be my basically my mentor
because he's he's beneath him in the
rank after he got stabbed after he got
stabbed he's like that was metal as [__]
he's like I really loved how you use
that knife well a lot of these wrestler
guys are nuts man you kind of have to be
a little right yeah so new Jack agrees
and he goes okay cool yeah let's do that
and uh this is in in Florida at the time
and then he goes yeah I'll I'll totally
like drop charges just be my my mentor
agrees to it the guy drops the charges
and then new Jack immediately leaves
Florida and never comes back for like
years oh [__] he doesn't even Mentor him
no he does not he does not that's [__]
up he does none of that dude his poor
guy's like dude was it something I said
did I not sell them I let him stab me
yeah here's here's a really funny quote
so this is him like a few years ago
talking about the incident this is a
really funny thing that he said about it
rope and I pulled a knife out
you moving like nine times come on
TV there's on the news this table 16 but
it was nine like I did only count nine
okay and I guess there's only like what
like 30 40 people in the audience
I mean I remember seeing the the dark
side of the Ring like you see the
audience and people were like holding
the hands over their mouths like just
terrified that this was happening yeah
uh and someone called the police yeah
the police showed up guns drawn yep
were you worried at all that you're
gonna get shot at that point here here
you are in what Tennessee wait where
were you guys
in Florida yeah okay even worse he
Florida you just stabbed up a white man
and the police show up not really
knowing the situation
well how'd you feel at that point
I knew I was going to jail
take me to jail you got me
okay and I guess one of the cops
cops yeah he did
okay what would you answer I started
laughing
he's so matter of fact this [__]
is crazy like you think he's gonna
explain himself but he just goes yeah I
did that yeah no I did that yeah yeah he
really doesn't have it I think 13 times
it was nine it was nine I don't know
what a bunch of sensationalist media
yeah this dude is like he's like a
larger than life character but in 2021
he did pass away of a heart attack
because uh he's on a lot of painkillers
from all of his like all his pains yeah
he's like going through his body's
jacked up so he's like having to take so
many pills and then heart couldn't take
it he had a lot of clots going on and
his dad's out of a heart attack too
though he wasn't the fan his dad died of
heart attack too [__] yeah so for those
of you who are wondering who knew Jack
is that's essentially his highest points
but there's if you think that's it
there's so many other incidents in
wrestling that he's had that are so
crazy he also the craziest one that you
didn't mention is that he took the
stunner in 2007.
he took the stunner yeah he got up he
got right up he got he took the stone
cold Center in 2007 at WrestleMania he
did and he got right up after that he
actually kept up yeah and they had an
ambulance pulled up and everything they
were ready yeah and he got right up
which doesn't happen he put a neck brace
on him and he ripped it off
it's insane it was honestly the craziest
thing I've ever seen in wrestling it was
in like yeah it was like top 20 moments
in Wrestlemania history wow I didn't
know that yeah because this guy didn't
do his research on it
is like independent wrestling [__] no I
saw the Undertaker taking her for
example just to give you
some context
Undertaker got kicked off the ring into
a coffin yeah yeah he rolled he rolled
in there he buried him alive the coffin
that he brought he got thrown back in
yeah
and you were expecting him to do this to
sit up he never did it I didn't do it he
got buried alive he was almost dead that
was the second time Undertaker died
that's one stunner same one the same one
so stupid
[Music]
foreign